bonsoir à tous merci d'être avec nous
dans tout ce sera mon poste ce soir on
voulait absolument démarrer cette
émission par une minute de silence suite
au drame qui s'est passé vendredi
dernier puisque samuel pâtit professeur
d'histoire géographie dans un collège
des yvelines a été sauvagement assassiné
par un terroriste
j'ai entendu que potentiellement il ya
des gens qui pensaient rebaptisé le
collège à conflans comme le collège
samuel bâti allez-y les mecs on a peur
de quoi de la digue encore malades
quelque part et nous font peur mais on
va pas leur montrez vous pouvez
rebaptiser ce collège monsieur samuel
pâtit que les enfants aillent à l'école
tous les matins et qu'on leur dise tu as
quel collège toi je suis apathie ckoi
pas ti pas ti c'est un mec qui est mort
pour la république est mort pour la
laïcité voilà ce qu'a sympathie jeudi
tout je les dis tu sais que ton
producteur est mon meilleur ami jean
rachid et je le dis j'ai entendu a
changé dit j'adore fabien mais je
supporte pas cette chanson jeu mais je
te dis toute la vérité
je voulais supportait pas cette chance
au creps raison et il m'a dit réécoute
la gelée rap et je supporte toujours pas
malgré tout là j'ai rappelé et au bout
de ma foi il ya monté dans ma voiture
et qu'est ce que j'écoutais je t'aime on
a écouté parfois c'est bon ça les 40
millions de singles et moi aussi
trambly il c'est un chanteur de ouf
mais c'est aussi un danseur et oui et ce
soir c'est peut-être le moment un être
le moment de voir la battle theme et on
rêvait tous angliche face à celui qu'on
appelle plus anna qu'on appelle plus
baba continence celui qu'on appelle d'un
seul nom l'animal
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
ça
chants mais c'était sur mes adversaires
amateurs ça fait plaisir
on a joué sur ton travail ce même accord
sur le bien voilà c'est parti
jimmy
[Applaudissements]
faux
on n'a pas droit de faire le même pas à
chaque fois
[Applaudissements]
non
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya plein de gens j'ai vu sur les
réseaux sociaux codeem mais laurent
requis chez cyril coomans à ce fait ils
sont pas fâchés mais en fait je vous le
dit et on va faire un détecteur de
mensonges thaler on peut dire qu'on n'a
jamais été fâché
à aucun moment nous n'avons jamais on
n'a eu voilà on sait qu on a eu des
trucs par près d'un abri on s'est un peu
charrié tous deux n'ont n'a jamais été
vraiment fâché laurent et moi j'ai béni
oui oui on a reçu il ya deux trois
semaines jean pierre pernaut qui nous a
dit qu'ils pouvaient pas vous plairait
de la question est ce que vous pensez de
lui et si à quelqu'un que vous ne pouvez
pas blairer aussi dans le milieu non moi
je n'ai jamais il ya quelqu'un dont je
dis je peux pas blairer parce que par
exemple jean pierre bouretz jean pierre
pernaut seraient pleins de rêves
j'aime plutôt bien jean-pierre nan parce
que bull charge aujourd'hui en revanche
que j'aimais pas les sujets qui traitait
mais ça c'est une question de goût moi
en revanche contrairement à lui je ne me
serais jamais permis de dire je ne peux
pas le blairer c'est pas ça n'a pas
vraiment fait ce qu'il a dit koné pa 1
connaît pas une connaît pas elle c'est
sa femme caniza mélanie qui l'a dit
alors ah les plus connus pour les
chroniqueurs qui sont ici mais
l'émission c'est cyril hanouna
mais c'est vrai que c'est pour moi vous
êtes un bon animateur et un nom
fantaisiste
j'appelle ça comme ça parce que et c'est
un conflit banal jeu combien les
chansons de charles aznavour et gémit
d'autres paroles dessus à vous de
trouver les deux interprètes vous jouez
avec nous bien sûr chez vous sur twitter
et vous jouez avec nous aussi
autour de la table voici la première
chance c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu parles avec une à une à une à une à
10 heures mais moi je m'appelle walden
oui je m'appelle weather
l'étude
es tu au
[Musique]
ce qui valorise sa peine chez qui la
belle j'ai pas fumer
[Musique]
votre sens et ma chérie tu es à
contresens mais dis moi tu étais où
quand je m'étais 7 euros d'essence je
fais passer la bague acquis qu'il ya
deux mois après celle et déjà quitté un
petit tabac ouais jeudi à quitter
ah non ce n'est pas la capitale c'est
marseille 3 au 10 sport se passe la
douane et je passe les rapports
attention alors
[Musique]
nico
ça
[Musique]
alors pour vous est ce que vous aviez
dupont de ligonnès est vivant ah oui je
le crois depuis le depuis le premier
jour pour vous y rendre
d'abord parce qu'il faut beaucoup de
courage pour situer leur faut plus pour
suer que pour donner l'adolescent
s'était tué moi ce que je vois c'est
qu'on l'aurait retrouvée on aura
retrouvé le corps non non pourquoi non
hayon non non je pense pas enfin je
pense pas s'il avait pris un cargo et
qu' il prend un litre de whisky des
médicaments et puis qui se pare de subir
est en couple on le retourne au nom mais
c'est simple pour moi que ce n'était pas
dans ses projets et puis quand vous
voyez tout le mode opératoire qui
remonte quand même un nom avant les
crimes
vous comprenez que c'est un mec qui veut
pas mourir et un garçon qui va chercher
son fils deux jours après alors qu'il a
tué toute la famille qui va le chercher
à la gare en sachant que une heure après
sa mort c'est quelqu'un qui qui voit
loin pour vous les ou alors il ya
plusieurs thèses il ya eu une thèse
assez assez forte sur la thaïlande
parce qu'il ya pas d'extradition il ya
cette fameuse théorie dont je parle
c'est la théorie des trois frontières
c'est-à-dire que quand si vous vous
cachez dans l'ordre la thaïlande que
vous êtes prêt de l'onu la haut de la
birmanie le vietnam
vous pouvez en une nuit franchir une
frontière si vous êtes repéré et xavier
quand il était assez il savait le
commentaire la problématique des
fugitifs en cavale s'attaquer à mon
équipe à vous et il s'est attaqué
notamment maroni regardez mais oui
regardez le chroniqueur n'est pas citée
que pensez vous de regarder que pensez
vous des gens de télé qui disent que
vous devriez j'imagine que vous faites
allusion à la bande de tpm p je ne vise
personne mais je pense que certains
chroniqueurs ferait mieux d'aller cuvée
leur pastis sur la porte de donner leur
perdition pas c'est de bonne guerre
moi je supporte pas d'être mince assez
basique yves abord le pastiche et le
poids mais quelle corde à vent d'abord
je vous parle de pression on va le
rappeler parce que y'a toujours attaquer
nos pauvres zhéros rouille et c'est pour
ça que j'ai parlé de toi
mais s'il y avait six calmes et un peu
plus mesuré dans ses propos avaient
route et ben sont les mieux aller
j'aurais fermé ma gueule
il était là je te dis que tu es petit tu
l'as dans le jura la coque travail oat
et sujet avant de parler de contrôle à
cerner son rôle et son épouse michelle
s'il vous plaît michel cymes devant là
je comprends absolument rien du tout
alors c'est cyril hanouna nombreuses
alors rené malleville où je connais un
petit peu le gie parti j'ai parlé du
professeur raoul est effectivement et
j'ai évoqué martèle j'ai jamais parlé de
rené malleville a encore moins du pastis
la caisse ayant des amis qui buvaient de
l'anisette mais il met le style jamais
quand tu as fait une connerie et et
j'allais me dégonfler devant lui
on sait qu'on soir de l'émission que
c'est mon choix on va afficher dans
l'écran des secrets qui correspondent à
nos chroniqueurs vous allez devoir de
mineurs et devinez quel chroniqueur à ce
secret qui a peur des ananas pas moi
sinon moi je pense que bernard hopkins a
pas très doué pour de dallas j'ai la
phobie les ananas
non non non non non non non non je suis
levé phobique en valeur des sables
c'est sûr j'ai eu la chance de partir à
lui à tahiti et le les organisateurs le
voulons faire plaisir le mont fait faire
une randonnée en quad au milieu d'eux et
on a fait un une partie dans un champs
d'ananas et j'ai failli perdre
connaissance non vers la mer je suis
personne et personne à personne ne voit
la personne ne doit m'écouter mais si
j'ai un message à faire passer je pense
qu'il faut vraiment qu'on arrive à tous
être soudé parce que la cia une dérive
incroyable en ce moment et je peux vous
dire que là le monde est en train de
partir en cacahuète et la france en ce
moment fait peur à tout le monde on va
en parler dans un instant dans balances
ton pote bien entendu mais c'est vrai
que là c'est encore un exemple et la
mettre les uns les incontrôlée de se
mettre les uns contre les autres c'est
pas du tout la bonne solution
[Musique]